♪ ♪
>> Hannity: COMEDIAN
DAVE CHAPPELLE WAS ATTACKED
DURING A PERFORMANCE OF THE
HOLLYWOOD BOWL VIDEO SHOWS A MAN
RUSHING ONTO THE STAGE TACKLING
DAVE CHAPPELLE BEFORE BEING
SURROUNDED BY SECURITY AND BEING
DETAINED NOW THE 23-YEAR-OLD
ASSAILANT WAS REPORTEDLY
CARRYING A REPLICA GUN WITH A
KNIFE BLADE INSIDE IT AND HE IS
NOW BEEN CHARGED WITH ASSAULT
WITH A DEADLY WEAPON NOW
DAVE CHAPPELLE IS OKAY HE EVEN
JOKED ABOUT THE ATTACK RIGHT
AFTER IT HAPPENED A SPOKESPERSON
FOR DAVE CHAPPELLE TELLS
FOX NEWS THAT HE IS FULLY
COOPERATING WITH THE POLICE IS
INVESTIGATE WHAT THEY CALL AN
UNFORTUNATE AND UNSETTLING
INCIDENT.
FOOTAGE FROM OUTSIDE THE
INCIDENT SHOWS THE ATTACKER WHEN
CARRIED AWAY ON A STRETCHER WITH
A PRETTY SERIOUS LOOKING ARM
INJURY NOW CHRIS ROCK SLAP HEARD
AROUND THE WORLD HE WAS ALSO IN
ATTENDANCE LAST NIGHT APPARENTLY
JOKED ABOUT THE INCIDENT ASKING
WAS AT WILL SMITH?
'S REACTION A HOST OF
PIERS MORGAN UNCENSORED WHOSE
AIRS NEW EPISODES FOR TIMES A
WEEK WHEN YOU GO TO
FOXNation.com ACROSS THE POND
WE LOVE TO SEE PIERS MORGAN.
WHEN I WATCH THE SLAP HEARD
AROUND THE WORLD WITH WILL SMITH
PART OF ME WAS LIKE OKAY IF
YOU'RE THAT SENSITIVE ONCE YOU
TALK IT OUT, IT WAS AN
OVERREACTION.
NOW WE SEE THIS ATTACK AGAINST
DAVE CHAPPELLE I HAVE AND I
THINK THAT CHRIS ROCK,
DAVE CHAPPELLE, LARRY THE CABLE
GUY, EVERY IRREVERENT COMEDIAN I
LOVE THOSE GUYS WHERE PEOPLE
REACTING THIS WAY TO JOKES?
>> I THINK SEAN IT'S A NATURAL
EXTENSION OF WHAT YOU SEE ALL
DAY LONG ON TWITTER ON THE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS WHERE YOU
SEE THIS CANCEL CULTURE RUNNING
AROUND WITH THINGS THAT ONLY
THEIR VIEWS ABOUT ISSUES IS
ACCEPTABLE AND ANYONE THAT
DIFFERS FROM THAT VIEW HAS TO BE
SHAMED, ABUSED, PUNISHED,
CANCELED, AND I WERE SEEING IT
MANIFEST ITSELF VIOLENCE.
IT IS VERY SINISTER DEVELOPMENT
THEY ARE COMEDIANS THEY CAN'T
TELL IRREVERENT JOKES ON STAGE
WITHOUT A FEAR OF BEING SMASHED
IN THE FACE OR WORSE, THIS GUY
HAD A WEAPON THAT COULD HAVE
KILLED DAVE CHAPPELLE AND WAS A
TAKE FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION?
OR COMEDY SO I THINK IT'S ALL
VERY UNSETTLING AND THE
CONSEQUENCE OF WHAT WOULD SOLVE
THE OSCARS I WAS A BIT LIKE YOU
I WAS KIND OF IN A WAY A SCENE
OUT OF A BARROOM BRAWL BETWEEN
ONE GUY DISSING ANOTHER MAN'S
WIFE.
BUT NOW I KIND OF THINK YOU KNOW
SET A VERY BAD PRECEDENT THE
PRESIDENT IS NOW BEING
REPLICATED BECAUSE I THINK IF I
WAS COMEDIAN RIGHT NOW LIKE
DAVE CHAPPELLE ARE THESE GUYS
WITH A BIG FOLLOWING IN FRONT OF
A BIG AUDIENCE IF WE WALK ON
STAGE NOW CHRIS ROCK IS ANYWHERE
NEAR YOU WEARING ABOUT OR PINCH
OF COMING FROM?
>> Hannity: YOU'RE TIRED OF A
CULTURE I'VE BEEN ON FOX FIRST
26 AND HALF YEARS.
IN ALL MY TIME ON THE AIR I
NEVER CALLED FOR ANY PERSON TO
BE FIRED, AND HE SHOWED TO BE
CANCELED, ANY SHOW TO BE
BOYCOTTED ONE THING PEOPLE SEEM
TO FORGET IS THAT AUDIENCES THEY
HAVE A CHOICE, THEY DON'T HAVE
CLOSE TO A RADIO SHOW, THEY
DON'T THE WATCH A TV SHOW, THEY
DON'T HAVE TO GO TO A COMEDY
SHOW HERE.
WHAT PART OF FREEDOM IN ALL OF
THIS PEOPLE MISSING BECAUSE WHEN
I GO LIKE A FAMILY GO WATCH
COMEDIAN I WANT NO HOLDS BARRED,
SAY ANYTHING YOU WANT AND IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SO EASILY
OFFENDED STAY HOME.
I'M NOT OFFENDED.
DAVE CHAPPELLE IS FUNNY HE'S
IRREVERENT HE'S POLITICALLY
INCORRECT, I THINK IS ONE OF US
COMEDIANS OUT THERE.
ALONG WITH CHRIS ROCK.
>> ALSO WHAT I ALSO THINK IS
UNSETTLING IS THAT HE'S COME
UNDER A LOT OF FIRE
DAVE CHAPPELLE FOR SOME NETFLIX
SPECIAL WHERE HE ADDRESSES THIS
WHOLE ISSUE OF TRANSGENDER IS
HIM IN AMERICA.
AND YOU RAISE SOME REALLY
INTERESTING POINTS ABOUT IT THE
INEQUALITY FOR EXAMPLE IN
SPORTS.
RISING OF THESE ISSUES.
THEY SHOULD BE DEBATING AND A
FREE DEMOCRATIC SOCIETY BY THE
UNITED STATES.
AND IT SHOULD HAVE A BIGGER
DEBATE AND ARGUE AND REACH
POINTS OF CONSENSUS.
BUT THAT'S NOT ALLOWED SO
DAVE CHAPPELLE MADE SOME JOKES
ABOUT THE TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY
I THINK THERE WERE TRANSPHOBIC I
THINK SHE'S HAVING FUN I THINK
SAME WITH EVERYONE.
BUT IN RETURN FOR THAT HE GOT
DEATH THREATS, YET THREATS
AGAINST HIS FAMILY, HE HAD UP
HIS SECURITY AND I WAS SEEN
BEING ATTACKED ON STAGE AND
COMES BACK TO WHAT I SET ABOUT
THIS NEW CANCEL CULTURE.
IS THAT IN A WAY IT'S A FORM OF
THE VERY FASCISM THAT THE
SO-CALLED LIBERALS WHO PROFESS
TO BEING WOKE AS A FORM OF
FASCISM THAT THEY SAY THAT THEY
HATE MOST IN LIFE.
SO THEY'RE GOING AROUND TRYING
TO DICTATE WILL BE TRY TO FIND
WHAT'S ACCEPTABLE WHAT'S FUNNY,
WHAT'S SUPPOSED OR ALLOWED TO
WATCH ON TELEVISION AND MOVIES,
WHAT STATUES WE CAN REVEAL, WHAT
HISTORICAL FIGURES WE CAN
RESPECT AND SO ON.
IF YOU DON'T TOE THE LINE
NOTHING WILL USE VIOLENCE TO
MAKE YOU DO IT.
THAT IS FASCISM.
AND IT SHOULDN'T BE HAPPENING IN
MODERN-DAY AMERICA OR BRITAIN OR
ANYWHERE ELSE.
THE SO-CALLED DEMOCRACY.
>> Hannity: ALL THE YEARS HAVE
BEEN A MEDIA NOT ONCE HAVE I
EVER BEEN TO THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER.
MY RECORD STANDS I DIDN'T SHOW
UP THIS YEAR, APPARENTLY IT
TURNED OUT TO BE A SUPER
SPREADER EVENT ANYWAY SOME GOT
IT AND GO.
[LAUGHS]
I'M NEVER BEEN ONCE.
I'M NEVER MY ENTIRE LIFE THOUGHT
THAT TREVOR NOAH WAS FUNNY, I
WATCH THE SHOW SEEM LIKE EVERY
OTHER COMEDIAN LATE-NIGHT
COMEDIAN TO LIBERAL SO IS
ONE-SIDED, I WASHED SOME CLUBS
AFTER HE WENT AFTER FOX NEWS,
CNN, VACANCY AND NEWS, CNN PLUS,
HE WENT AFTER REPUBLICANS HE
WENT AFTER DEMOCRATS WHEN AFTER
TRUMP, HE WENT AFTER EVERYBODY I
SAID WOW FOR THE FIRST TIME HE'S
FUNNY.
GO AHEAD.
WHY THESE LATE-NIGHT COMEDIANS
TRY TO FORCE A POLITICAL AGENDA?
>> I THINK TREVOR NOAH HE MADE A
VERY GOOD POINT I'VE BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT OVER THE YEARS
BUT I THINK IT'S VERY GOOD JOB
BECAUSE HE MADE THIS POINT THAT
WHEN YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
UKRAINE WHEN YOU SEE WHAT
HAPPENS IN RUSSIA OR CHINA AND
NORTH KOREA.
WE SEE ALL THIS GOING ON IT'S
REALLY ABOUT CANCELING PEOPLE'S
RIGHT TO FREE SPEECH AND
EXPRESSION WHEN HE TURNS TO
JOE BIDEN'S AND I'M ALLOWED TO
INSULT THE PRESENT UNITED STATES
SITTING A FEW FEET AWAY FROM ME,
THAT WAS A POWERFUL MOMENT WHERE
I THINK EVERY PERSON IN AMERICA
AND EVERYONE AROUND THE WORLD TO
LOOK AT THAT MOMENT AND REFLECT
WHAT HAPPENED ON DAVE CHAPPELLE.
HOW CAN BE THAT TREVOR NOAH IS
ALLOWED TO DO WHAT HE DID AT THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS'
DINNER AND THAT'S FREE SPEECH AT
ITS BEST AND HOW AT THE SAME
TIME ARE YOU SEEING PEOPLE
ATTACKING COMEDIANS FOR MAKING
JOKES BECAUSE THEY DON'T THINK
THAT THEY ARE ENTITLED TO MAKE
THAT JOKE WITHOUT GETTING
VIOLENCE AGAINST THEM.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
>> Hannity: SOMEONE'S GOT TO
HURT.
>> SOME GUY COULD KILL THEM.
AND IF DAVE CHAPPELLE WAS
STABBED TO DEATH BY THE SKY.
>> Hannity: OCCUR BEEN REALLY
BAD.
>> IMAGINE THAT MOMENT WHERE
COMEDIAN WAS KILLED FOR COMEDY,
THAT WOULD BEEN A TERRIBLE
MOMENT.
MORE MOMENTS LIKE TREVOR NOAH
MOCKING THE PRESIDENT SING A FEW
FEET AWAY FROM THEM IS A LOT
LESS TOLERANCE ABOUT WHAT WENT
ON WITH DAVE CHAPPELLE.
>> Hannity: WE ONLY HAVE ABOUT
A MINUTE LEFT WE SPOKE LAST TIME
WHEN YOU'D WALKED OFF
GOOD MORNING BRITAIN THE NUMBER
ONE MORNING SHOW NOW TO THE TANK
WITHOUT YOU THAT'S MAKE YOU
REALLY PROUD [LAUGHS]
WE TALKED ABOUT MEGHAN MARKLE
AND A LOT OF THE PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT OFF, IS.
BUT I THINK YOU'RE GONNA KNOW
PRETTY SOON YOU HEARD ABOUT THIS
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
PROPOSAL OF A MINISTRY OF TRUTH
AGAINST DISINFORMATION.
ORGAN OF THE GOVERNMENT DECIDE
THAT, HOW BAD DID YOU GET IN
BRITAIN?
THIS MIGHT BE A PREVIEW OF
COMING ATTRACTIONS HERE.
>> TO ME THE PRINCIPLE OF HAVING
A GOVERNMENT TRYING TO REGULATE
FREE SPEECH IS JUST WRONG.
I NEVER BELIEVED IN IT HERE.
I KNOW WE ACCEPTED HER FRANKLY
BUT WE DO.
BUT AMERICAN PARTICULARLY WITH
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
A TUMMY BELIEVED THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY FOR YOU TO
TAKE FREE SPEECH FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BY THE WAY OF REPRESENTING A
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW
WITH A DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT WHEN
THE LAST FEW YEARS ALONE I'VE
WATCHED AS THEY PEDDLED THE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION NONSENSE I
WATCH THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP
SCANDAL BEING SUPPRESSED AND SO
ON.
IS THAT THEIR IDEA FREE SPEECH?
BECAUSE IT'S THE PEOPLE WHO DID
THAT ARE NOW CAN I DICTATE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT FREE SPEECH
IS THAT'S A REALLY CONCERNING
MOLD MOMENT.
AND IT SHOULD BE HAPPENING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO EXPRESS THEMSELVES IN
ANY WAY THEY SEE FIT.
AT THE GOVERNMENT IS REALLY
SERIOUS ABOUT DISINFORMATION
LOOK TO YOUR OWN BACKYARD AND
STOP PEDDLING YOUR OWN
DISINFORMATION.
AND THAT'S WHY AMERICAN IN
BRITAIN MY MESSAGE IS DIRECTLY
TO GOVERNMENTS.
ON SOME OF THE STUFF THEY COME
OU